joining me now representing the great
state of Ohio Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan congressman thanks so much for
being here all right I want to continue
with this conversation Nancy Pelosi look
you know she's over there eating her
high-price ice cream I don't know what
she's doing and you know she's
complaining about the president let's
talk about the fact that it appears that
the Democrats are using this Wu Han
virus they want to call it covin
whatever that means as a subterfuge to
pursue their progressive leftist
Democratic agenda as opposed to
providing money needed dollars to
Americans what's that yeah no you're
exactly right judging the senator is
exactly right the Democrats never miss
an opportunity to do two things go after
President Trump and then try to advance
their crazy left-wing agenda think about
what they're saying right now during
this virus they're saying illegal
immigrants should go free they're say
we're going to pay States think about
that pay states to let criminals out of
jail they say abortion clinics are quote
essential businesses and they want to
stop you from buying a gun and they want
to stop you from going to church that's
what the Democrats are for during this
this time when as the senator said we
should be coming together to deal with
this virus and as the president said get
our country back to work as quickly as
we can so the Republicans we want to go
back to work we want to make sure the
small business loan program has the
resources it needs to help business
owners and families we want to go back
to work and be doing the work of the
American people
Nancy Pelosi wants to stay in San
Francisco and criticize the president
who as the senator said is doing a darn
good job oh well but you know the
amazing part of it is what the original
cares Act and then look the payment
protection plan is out of money all
right there are the money and there are
people who need that money to survive
all right in the meantime she's taking
money out of that 2.2 trillion dollar
stimulus bill to dance around with the
Kennedy Center as if the philanthropist
can't give that Kennedy Center money
Americans need that money how'd you guys
let that get out of a car out of the
house no you're exactly right we and we
should be back at work doing the work of
making sure that that paycheck
protection program has the resources it
needs to help small businesses and help
families but we've got all these tasks
meeting the one at the White House that
the Vice President is overseeing is
doing a great job there are other task
force around the country meeting but the
one task force that's supposed to meet
to address big issues that face our
nation is the United States Congress and
we're not in session and the Speaker of
the House says we're not even coming
back into session until May fourth
meanwhile the state of Texas is going
back to work
this next week and frankly health care
workers law enforcement truckers grocers
warehouse me all kinds of people have
been working where's the United States
Congress so it is time we get back to
work do the work anymore and one of the
things we should do judge particularly
on the Judiciary Committee we should be
looking at the very thing you talked
about in your opening monologue
we should be looking at the threats to
Liberty we see where governors are
saying you're going to get a ticket if
you go to church where the mayor of Los
Angeles one of our biggest cities the
mayor of Los Angeles said snitches will
be rewarded what kind of message is that
we had a prosecutor in one of our big
counties in Ohio a prosecutor said if he
were the governor he would call out the
National Guard to stop you from going to
church so we need to be back focused on
that issue and here's one other good
piece of good information from the
Attorney General earlier this week he
put out a memo talking about religious
liberty was a great memo saying you
can't do the things that are being done
by some of these governors oh they can't
that's how I did the open it is
unconstitutional it doesn't give them a
Destroyers if I want to see one more
thing look as a prosecutor every time
you get a conviction you prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that someone is guilty
and you know what it takes to get
someone to get a judge to send someone
to jail
now they're telling everybody okay let
the criminals out of jail I'm over here
I'm staying in my house they're telling
me I can't leave I can't play ball with
it but with us with a child I can't go
to church and you're letting criminals
out of jail I mean I hope Americans are
hearing this and even worse they ran out
of money it is it is a shame but anyway
Congressman Jim Jordan we always love
having everyone justice